I am so happy that we decided to stay in
I think we made the right decision
big time Charles you don't even like my
friends I hate your friends yeah who
needs to be out with 30 lads when I can
be at home with one special person no
it's like you just end up breaking the
mid January and then you feel even more
depressed than you were before
no I I don't really want to lose weight
and yeah
smoke rages yes it's not really
that kind of resolution is more like an
emotional one
what do you mean you know I trying to
trying to be a better person
so I trying to get your better self to
hold your worst self a bit more so
account birth I think it's you really
yeah okay
I want to start being a bit more honest
about what's on my mind rather than
getting you to guess and then getting
furious when you get it wrong
so if I've had a bad day at work and I'm
ratty then instead of being ratty I just
want to tell you they've had a bad day
at work okay so you know when I get
really annoyed and maybe you haven't
quite spotted what it is you've done to
annoy me but I just don't tell you and I
make you feel really really bad and I
drag it out for ages I'm not gonna do
that I'm just gonna tell you what's
wrong I want to stop taking things so
personally and makes her sensitive about
everything if you're having a bad day of
being sad or angry or whatever I don't
want to always assume that it's to do
with me because it could be to do with
something completely different like your
mom well you've had a bad day or
whatever I just I guess I have to stop
supposing that I'm to blame
so you know I have this habit of saying
nothing when it's clearly something I
think it's because anytime it comes to
difficult feelings I just want to run
away from them I can be quite evasive so
it's as if I kind of need to leave the
drawbridge down a bit you know it's like
I'm a kind of very well defended
fortress to let me be to let you win
yeah
I think I want to be as good a teacher
as you are because you helped me realize
so much about myself and sometimes I
want to do the same but I'm too scared
and I get anxious that you won't listen
and then obviously you don't listen
because I'm being all anxious and scared
and who wants to listen to that so I
want to be as good a teacher as you are
picking the right moment when I'm calm
when you're calm yeah I want to be a
better teacher I always find you really
attractive but I think I do have that
thing sometimes I just don't want you to
touch me
and I know that sounds really weird but
I think it's because I might actually be
feeling really angry and it's something
but I haven't dealt with or maybe I've
even forgotten that I'm angry myself so
it's manifesting as this kind of
numbness so I guess I need to just pick
up on those danger signs a bit sooner so
I don't end up rejecting you and yeah
just keep all of that anguish out of the
bedroom
I am a complete I am a nob I
frequently get things wrong I always
think I'm right and I've got the feeling
that this year I'm gonna cause you a lot
of psychological and spiritual pain okay
I don't purpose that's wine I'm gonna
keep making you terrible risottos on
purpose and they're gonna be crunchy and
horrible I yeah and I'm really grateful
to have you in my life I'm very grateful
and I know it can be really difficult
sometimes I'm always a pleasure to be
around but occasionally misinterpret
that mr. kay to me but it's normally
because I'm confused or sad and angry or
whatever yeah I think it's because I'm
anxious or angry do you think maybe it's
just possible yeah I'm gonna be this is
a work yeah I'm sensing a common theme
yes
[Music]
you
we love bringing you these films if you
want to help us to keep bringing you
thoughtful content please consider
supporting us by visiting our shop at
the link on your screen now
you